here it is
30 years from now last question for you
since you're good at
imagining what the future will look like
what does america look like
well we're coming to an inflection point
and i think we're
we are in the
1977
you know the the carter administration
if you think about the 70s was a major
setback for the west we had all kinds of
foreign foreign policy setbacks she had
inflation and stagflation and high
unemployment and the oil crises and all
the rest
and we just had um
uh
like a what what did carter say we had a
malaise yeah and and leadership
can turn it around just like leadership
can turn a failed business around
surprisingly quickly good leadership can
turn a country around
yes our congress
is useless and in the wrong direction
but there's a reason the founding
fathers set it up so that every two
years you can throw the bums out yup do
so
um the same with senate you can turn
over a third of those senators
uh every two years
the country requires leadership and
whether that's uh election integrity
if
you do that on your local basis and if
you know
i think the biggest problems in america
stem from the fact that the federal
government has gotten way too large
and and i think we need to maximize the
10th amendment
states rights limiting the powers of the
federal government to stuff that has
only been directly entitled to the
federal government to do otherwise it's
left to the states and so states have to
be much stronger
at flexing those muscles and say no
we're not going to pay for your
stupidity anymore washington that's
exactly we're doing our thing
i said that's my last question but i
have to get to this so this is your book
which is excellent
civilian warriors the inside story of
black water
page 180.
you have this picture and i don't know
if we can come in on this it's right
it's right here and it says three then
senators joe biden chuck hagel and john
kerry the future vice president
secretary of defense and secretary of
state respectively pose while waiting
for blackwater rescue
what is that
yeah so they were on a congressional
visit to afghanistan in the winter and
their u.s army helicopter got lost in a
blinding snowstorm and sat down in
taliban territory on the side of a
mountain and
the us military launched a ground convoy
to get them and they got lost and the
blackwater guys launched and they did
not get lost and we recovered them we
rescued them from taliban territory
i think that was the winter of oh eight
you rescued joe biden and john kerry and
chuck hagel
afraid so
are they grateful
you wouldn't think so no
did did i go biden write you a thank you
note i didn't get a christmas card have
yet to